56 million abortions occur annually
worldwide and though opinions on the
matter are strong many are simply
unaware of how they actually work so
regardless of whether you're pro-life or
pro-choice what actually happens during
an abortion abortion procedures range
from taking a pill to surgical options
often based on availability or how far
along a pregnancy is and 92% of legal
u.s. abortions take place within the
first thirteen weeks of gestation the
oral tablet is effective 49 days from
one's last menstrual period often
containing myth a proced known it works
by blocking the hormone progesterone
progesterone promotes smooth muscle
relaxation in the uterine wall
throughout pregnancy and so the pill
causes the uterus to contract and the
embryo to be expelled in what seems like
a heavy period vacuum aspiration is a
surgical procedure usually used up to 16
weeks after conception and is typically
performed under local or general
anesthesia the cervix is numbed and
opened wide enough to pass a slender
tube into the uterus or suction is used
to empty the contents within the same
timeline a DNC or dilation and curettage
abortion can be used first the cervix is
dilated using small instruments or
medication and then a curette is used to
remove the contents of the uterus if a
pregnancy is between 12 to 24 weeks a D
and E or dilation and evacuation
abortion is likely used although only
1.2 percent of abortions occur after 21
weeks in a DNA abortion the cervix needs
to be dilated wider often using osmotic
dilators which are short rods made of
seaweed or synthetic material which
absorb moisture and slowly stretch the
cervix
these are usually inserted the day
before surgery once dilated a fetal and
placental tissue is removed via vacuum
aspiration of forceps and a curette the
decision to have an abortion after 24
weeks is extremely rare and often due to
severe fetal anomalies when abortions
are allowed by the local law they are
one of the safest procedures in medicine
with case fatality rates less than
death per 100,000 procedures in the u.s.
the risk of death associated with
childbirth is 14 times higher in women
than that of an abortion
there are also myths that abortion is
linked to an increased risk of cancer as
well as difficulties in conceiving or
carrying a future pregnancy but both of
these claims have been refuted by
extensive medical research however
unsafe abortions practice by individuals
without the necessary skills or in an
environment that does not conform to
medical standards caused an estimated
68,000 women to die yearly while a
further five million suffer temporary or
permanent disability methods range from
ingesting toxic solutions inserting
foreign bodies into the uterus and even
trauma the World Health Organization has
called unsafe abortions a preventable
pandemic and laws that limit a woman's
access to an abortion or make abortions
illegal do not reduce the number of
abortions countries where abortions are
illegal have roughly the same number of
abortions what changes instead is the
incidence of unsafe abortions a 2011
study did find that state-level
anti-abortion laws in Texas correlated
with lower
abortion rates in the state but these
results did not account for women
traveling to other states with less
restrictive laws to receive a procedure
conversely researchers have found that
sex education and access to
contraceptive methods do reduce the
number of abortions by minimizing
unwanted pregnancies this can be seen in
the abortion rates decreasing
significantly in the developed world
since 1990 ultimately access to legal
abortions make women's lives safer and
healthier if you'd like to learn about
Plan B or emergency contraceptive which
is not the same thing as an abortion you
can check out our video on that here and
don't forget to subscribe for more
weekly science videos every Thursday
you